the jurgen experience you're asking me
about we're back yeah
you're asking me about you know why why
i get attracted to these kind of
subjects
and they don't seem attractive on the
surface but
when the more you get into them the more
they can be exciting uh
so i am a dramatist at heart i'm that
really that is my
what i do best which is to dramatize
situations take
something and bring it to life so take
taking the kennedy murder
it was extremely uh challenging
and i knew it could work i felt like it
could work and it was a surprise yeah
like platoon i mean basically how can
you take this
war is boring there's a lot of details i
was in four different units you know
time
not much happens and then suddenly
things happen it's not that easy to make
it happen in a movie time
movie space so i took two different
sergeants from two different units
and i imagine what would they be like if
they were in the same unit
they would they would clash one would be
the the law and order guy as a
guy who believed in what he was doing
and fought it viciously
and the other guy is the guy who was an
anti uh
who was a rebel who was like a bit like
my own character my father was much of a
law and order guy my mother was very
much a rebel
and i i kind of put that into this
conflict because i saw it in every
platoon
there was people who were like
doing marijuana people who were doing
alcohol you know there was that split
kind of and a lot of the black guys i
hung out with
were doing marijuana and they were doing
the
music the music was unbelievable but
they had a different kind of music than
the oaky music so it was all the split
in these platoons i saw
constantly black white and
country city sensibilities
also a very important point is that i
found over time that the law and order
guys
often were the most racist in terms of
coming down on the vietnamese civilians
because we used to
we had we did jungle duty but we also
did a lot of civilian villages
search and destroy search and whatever
search search them
we find stores weapons this that not
necessarily they were cooperating but
sometimes they were forced to
but a lot of guys screwed with them you
know didn't like the vietnamese at all
which was not the black problem that was
you know that was more of a it was a
white problem
so i found there was a lot of that going
on and
i i couldn't that was not my thing and i
just uh really didn't like what i saw
it's a lot of cowardice too can only
imagine
and that's a shock education i mean you
talk about like a
no escape just thrust into this
completely volatile chaotic world and
then introduced to a bunch of different
people that you weren't around
yeah and then when i got out i got
thrown into jail it's in the book too
you know
fought for for federal smuggling
marijuana
coming back from mexico how much did you
have
a few just an ounce or two really that's
it federal smuggling for announcements
i'd taken some vietnamese grass home oh
yeah
but i never went home i just went right
to mexico so it was a few days later i
was in the jail
wow called my father and said hey dad
you know i'm in trouble
i said why haven't you called me where
you've been for the we knew you got out
two weeks ago at fort lewis and i said
well i said dad i mean you want to hear
where i'm at you know and blah blah blah
and he got me out
he got me out with some money wow
without it i would have been sunk into
that prison
it was awful prison was filled with
blacks and latinos i mean there were 5
people in there for 2 000 beds that was
the beginning of the drug war
nixon was had been elected but had not
yet declared that war on drugs but it
was filled
or most of them are non-violent crimes
you see yeah and i saw that
that side of america coming out so we
have a lot of
law and order types here yes well that
law and order stuff was instituted when
they
they passed that sweeping psychedelics
acts of 1970 oh god
yeah well they what they were trying to
do is they were trying to squash the
civil rights movement that's a big part
of what they were trying to do they were
trying to
make everything incredibly illegal
schedule one
so that they could have a reason to
infiltrate these groups and start
arresting people
and break the groups up that's
absolutely correct yeah
and uh j edgar hoover was still around
unfortunately he was a lot of influence
on this
marijuana had been the devil drug what a
fascinating character he was
yeah just you know they never got him
yet on movies no
no god uh almost impossible to really i
i really wish there was more i mean real
personal
footage of all the crazy [ __ ] that he
was actually into
yeah we can get an understanding of how
nuts it was that this guy was in charge
of spying on people
and lyndon johnson you have to ask you
know did lyndon johnson really believe
the [ __ ] he was talking about the
the black
civil rights movement had a communist
basis
that the communism was supporting it i
mean that was very much hoover's
thesis yeah well they that was a great
way to get people motivated
to see your side of things back then you
know yeah
during the the whole cold war scare and
the red scare it's like
communism being a motivating factor for
any group
yeah yeah
you